[Music]
so
[Music]
banquet is the easiest safest
and simplest way for you to give food to
a food bank
when you donate we take your gift
combine it with others donations
buy in bulk so we get people more of the
things they need
when they need them we of course wish
that food banks didn't exist
but whilst they do we want to support
their amazing work
and help them help more people
[Music]
has been the home of displaced talent
for four years
we want to celebrate the charter blocks
family the 160 refugees
3 000 students and 20 companies around
the world
who believe in us who expanded their
minds and horizons with us
we couldn't do this without to you
you are changing the world one language
lesson
at the time
hello everyone i'm eduardo and i
co-founded the conveyor digital finance
shipping company based in paris london
and new york
the one stop shop platform generating
instant shipping rates
with a larger graphical scope what that
means is that by using our website or
integrating our plug-in
art market players can instantly quote
shipments
originating anywhere in europe and the
u.s and going to one of the 70
destinations we serve
[Music]
[Music]
infertility is a disease which affects
everyone it affects one in six
couples no matter what your background
and
treatment options end up with huge
amounts of
physical emotional and financial burdens
and what our mission is to do
is to ensure that women have access to
treatments which are more friendly to
their bodies
and which are affordable as well
[Music]
you